- Oh man.
Oh man!
We are so close to one another!
(guitar music)
We are so close.
- [Jill] I can see everything!
- How the heck do guys who are strangers
just pee in a big trough together?
- I can be a little pee shy.
- Jill and I especially are pee shy.
- I am, yeah.
- Maybe if everyone around us is doing it.
- Yeah.
Is it hard not to look?
Is it weird if you look?
- I wanna look.
I'm sorry, if you're gonna be right there
and you're this close.
- Please, no joke.
- I am interested to see if we can talk.
- I feel like not making
conversation is a weird thing.
- I talk when I'm nervous.
- I don't know what I
would do with my pants.
If you pull them down, if I
walked in and saw someone's butt
I mean, that would change everything.
If we don't have zippers,
how do you do that?
- What do you do?
- Are you just mooning?
Can you walk in and there's a man butt?
So we got up this morning
and we made these urinals.
Which are just like these
little buckets with bedpans.
- And we have three of
these for each of us.
- It's gonna be a bonding
experience for us.
- It is!
- I'm ready to try it.
- This is a step in women's exploration.
(guitar music)
- Oh man.
Oh man.
This is so intimate.
- I'm ready to go.
- Are we going?
Let's do it.
- Let's do it.
- Okay.
- This is so intimate!
- I see everything!
- Would two people really
just do this and not talk?
- Amy, what do I do with my panties?
- Mine are a little lower than my butt.
- I can't tell if I like Jill talking
or if I don't like Jill talking.
Jamie, why are you so comfy?
- I really had to go.
- Wait!
Oh my God, I'm peeing!
- I hear it!
- This is the weirdest experience ever!
- Why can't I pee?
- You can't?
I have faith in you!
- Jane was this weird at all for you?
- No, I thought it was actually easy.
- [Jill] Do it girl!
- Alright, well, I think I' gonna give up.
I don't feel it.
I don't even have to fo anymore.
Alright, zip up.
- [Voiceover] Isn't it a
lot closer than you think?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I was definitely
tighter to you than I thought.
- I looked over at Jamie
and she's "Whatever."
And I'm like well, shit.
If she can do it, I want to too.
- I think I really
realized how guys do this
in a lot of aspects,
but I still don't understand.
It must be really hard not to look.
- I feel like the one hard thing,
when you're trying to pee,
have a little conversation,
you look!
And if you look at someone's eyes, you do.
- We all secretly look and
just pretend like you don't?
- You do.
- [Amy] You have to.
Right?
- [Jamie] I don't think that they do.
- [Jill] I think they
totally make a quick check.
- I could do that all of the sudden
if you just had a little dispenser
with a little piece of toilet paper there.
(booping noises) and then done!
- Just one square.
- [Jamie] Yeah.
(guitar music)